The newest Rogue One trailer included some moments that provoked major nerding out
rom the Star Wars fans here in the Gamespot office.
Here are 3 potentially spoiler theories we came up with.
Jedha, the mecca of jedi religion definitely gets blown up.
There is a line in the last trailer about a "new weapons test" being imminent
and we think that Jedha is the target of that test.
Three of the Rogue One crew call Jedha home,
so that may be a major motivator to kick some imperial ass.
We think the whole Rebel fleet is going to get some action.
The presence of Nebulon-B escort frigates, mon calamari cruisers, and corellian corvettes
behind these x-wings are a good indication that the whole team came out to support.
This battle probably takes place in the orbital shipyards around the planet Scarif
where the Death Star was created.
Just like in Return of the Jedi we may see a battle happening concurrently in space and on land.
One on the surface of Scarif featuring cargo version of the AT-AT Walkers
and one in space with the previously mentioned Rebel fleet.
Okay, it's going to get really theoretical in here for a second.
I think Director Orson Krennic is going to redeem himself at the end,
because Darth Vader looks so pissed off in this scene.
Based on an early synopsis from a book coming out in November,
Krennic was an old friend of Galen Ersa, the lead character's father.
Maybe Vader is angry because he betray the Empire in the end to save his friends daughter.
Or maybe he just messes up and gets force choked.
We nerded out really hard on a two minute trailer
so when the movie actually comes out we might explode
For more on your favorite Comic books, TV shows and movies check out GameSpot Universe.